entrepreneurs and creatives nowadays
increasingly define themselves as
digitally nomadic these are people
obsessed with the idea of freedom
freedom from place freedom from
geography freedom from traditional
modalities of office work
freedom from routines people are hungry
for novelty people are hungry for travel
people are hungry for exposure to a
multiplicity of cultures and a
multiplicity of places and thankfully
we've arrived at a place where
technology can allow us to
simultaneously feel free while remaining
connected to feel free while maintaining
a level of productivity that actually
may exceed prior generations I'll give
you an example you got to make a deal
you got to start a company you got to
sign documents there used to be a time
where you were tethered to an office
somebody sent you a document which you
received through maybe an email then you
had to print it with this other device
called a printer then you had to sign it
with like an ink and a pen
then you had to scan it through this
thing called the fax that sent it
through the phone line that was received
on the other end all of this to
formalize an agreement to get a document
side today companies like sign Easy have
basically burst into the digital
marketplace in the form of an app on
your smartphone that allows you to
download a document to sign up with your
thumb out put it as a file and send it
without ever leaving your flow and ever
even having to be tethered to an office
so the dream is real you can be
gallivanting through Berlin bike riding
through Amsterdam enjoying a day and the
Sun set vibes in Tulum while being
productive signing documents sending
files all of it frictionless and all of
it
remaining and keeping you untethered my
friends we finally arrived at a place
where technology is potentiating the
human dream of
freedom and productivity it's happening
it's here